Scientists discover that individuals with
more brain activity learn slower than those
with less brain activity.
So stop thinking and learn! … wait what?!
Hi Everyone!
Crystal here for DNews exploring the idea
that over thinkers like me, may learn new
tasks more slowly and be less successful at
those tasks than those who don’t analyze
and evaluate their every move.
Scientists have known for a while that cognitive
control from the frontal cortex can have a
depressing effect on our ability to learn
new tasks.
This is probably because that brain region
is responsible for problem solving, planning
and execution, and its “top down” regulation
of our behavior can lead us to make things
more complicated for ourselves than they really
are.
Children learn wayyy faster than adults because
they are not subject to this cortical control.
They CAN’T over think because their judgy
frontal cortex hasn’t been fully developed
yet!
This is one reason why kids are more creative
and frequently take risks that an adult probably
wouldn’t.
When humans are exposed to a new task almost
our entire brain is active and desperately
trying to make sense and associations from
the new input.
As we get better at the task and “figure
it out” this global network activity gets
pruned to only what we need specifically for
task performance (eg. motor and visual cortices).
How quickly this specification happens corresponds
to how “quickly” we learn the task.
Researchers at several universities, looked
at this process across the whole brain and
recorded which regions maintained their connections
and activity, and which ones didn’t.
These data were recorded as fMRI scans of
whole brain as subjects learned a simple musical
computer game.
The scientists were hoping to visualize the
changes that happened as people learned, but
what they didn’t expect is that subject
data would organize itself into two categories:
“fast” learners and “slow” learners.
Those who learned the musical video game very
quickly showed rapid drop off of global brain
activation.
The “slow” learners maintained more global
brain activity over the six week trial and
showed prolonged involvement of associative
regions of the cortex.
This lead researchers to conclude that “over
thinking” - by maintaining vigilance, monitoring
errors, and frequently making associative
judgements - makes it more difficult for individuals
to “transform a task from slow and challenging
to fast and automatic”.
More studies are needed to truly understand
this process but it very well could be that
analyzing your thinking about thinking about
what you are trying to learn isn’t doing
you any favors and making it harder for you
to be successful.
So get out of your own way, stop second-guessing
and re-optimizing everything and just let
it happen!!
What do you think?
What task are you making more difficult for
yourself?